has the moment sunk in that you're facing your
childhood Idol on your NHL debut yet how much
pressure does that create in a situation like
this how you measure your own success tonight
how'd you sleep last night like a baby it's not
[Applause] good Connor Bard going to make his
debut tonight it's always electricity opening
night but is there a little more juice in the
building when the first overall picks making his
NHL debut there's a lot of hype around this game
obviously it's a real bright young player that
will inevitably emerge as a superstar he likes
the big moments and I think this is going to
be a special night for us to all be involved
and uh I'm just happy to be uh in the first seat
right behind watching I bet he's really excited
to start against a guy like S I think just enjoy
it you know first NHL game that's what you dream
of and you know there's a lot of expectations
and a lot of things going on around you but you
know that's a game that you look back on you know
no matter what with a lot of great memories so I
think you just try to soak it up and enjoy it
PPG Paints Arena here in Pittsburgh number one
overall pick 2005 Sydney Crosby head to-head with
number one overall pick this year Conor Bard you
got to be hard on the boards all right faster
the neutral zone and smart plays at their boo
line and play in the own L their Lots all right
we'll have a good night there all right so to
doing that we're going to start with Taylor
Conor and Ryan and last Seth Peter and the
ne the start of a new era in Chicago and perhaps
in the National Hockey League
as [Applause] [Music] [Applause]
well Bard and Crosby about to take the opening
face off in a moment Conor Bard has been dreaming
about for a long time hey Sid welcome back for
another season Conor good luck man welcome to the
NHL man okay guys it's show time let have a great
[Music] game go go go go middle go [Music] midddle
n n n n danger y right wing let tag to the front
[Applause] re the penguins have a one- nothing
lead hey rebound Bard had a great chance the punck
is free in the crease nice
pass I got the whole going in
there hey hey hey same thing Crosby
Center for gel back for s the kid he
scores it's 87 check it in on opening night
although this is going to be reviewed was
using a coach's challenge to determine if
the play was offside prior to the scoring
of the goal good huh good HT oh yeah I think
so Cory Perry he's always over here looking
at this he's going to do this when he retires
he should anyway and Chris lat Tang's already
looked at it so he's already made his decision
it looked all right to me when I was up there I
would think when I'm coming up I'd see white
if it was out you know I mean it will be TJ
luxmore the referee making the call after
review the play has been confirmed to be on
side the B will count Sydney Crosby with his
first of the year 1156 the [Applause] time
now leaves it for last closing in
down the left side Su the score let's
go let's go and Conor berard's got his first
National Hockey League point one let's go let's
go buddy Conor Bard in his National Hockey
League debut has a point on the board and
Donato's got his first as a Chicago Blackhawk
and 40 minutes are complete penguins with a
2-1 lead against the Chicago Blackhawks I'm
yet to win a draw yet to win a draw that is
that true I think I've tied like five but I
was really tough when you go against 87 he's
[Music] s centers Gutman scores Cole
Gutman has tied it at two with 955 to
go frantic action here in the third period
one timer one timer 820 to go here's Carlson
down low another big stop by morazzi kensel
looks Skyward he can't believe it we Center
iing over the penguin line left wing drops it
off Cory Perry put it over shot by Dickens and
he scores and the Hawks take a 3-2 lead over the
Penguins with 431 left in the third good job good
job I got it with the empty net the C the
Perry out in front and they [Applause] score
the Blackhawks come into Pittsburgh and score four
straight Bard and the Hawks an impressive win on
night what are you going to remember most about
tonight uh the winning yeah for [Music] [Applause]
sure to get a point and to win how would
you summarize your debut yeah it was a
lot of fun I mean to get the win I think
uh you know obviously being down two and
and coming back like we did I think it's
it's awesome for our group guys that was
work for from uh from first a training
camp all the way through this game there
nothing better than playing in the
NHL than winning in the [Applause]
NHL